Today I'm going to be showing you guys
five simple hacks that you can use to
make sure that Cloud Code is building
you websites that don't look like they
were AI vibe coded, but they actually
feel professional and branded. And we're
going to be going through this in a way
where even if you've never used Cloud
Code before, that's completely fine.
You're going to be able to by the end of
this video spin up some really awesome
looking landing pages and websites. All
right, so I don't want to waste any time
at all. The first thing that you need to
do is you need to go download Visual
Studio Code. So go to a browser and type
in VS Code and download this for your
operating system. This is essentially
just the IDE that we're going to be
using Cloud Code within. So once you've
done that and you've opened it up, this
is what it will look like. You're going
to go to the lefth hand side right here
and click on extensions and you're going
to type in cloud code and install it
like what you see right here. Now once
you do that, it's going to prompt you to
sign in with your Enthropic subscription
or your cloud subscription, which you do
need a paid account. As you can see
here, if you're on free, you don't have
access to Cloud Code, but here on Pro,
you actually can use Cloud Code. Whether
you're on pro or max, you can use it.
I'd probably just start with pro. If you
hit limits, which you probably will if
you want to, you know, build websites
all day, then you should probably
upgrade to max. So once you've got that
installed, you will see this little
button up here, which is cloud code. And
when you click on that, this is where it
opens up the ability to actually use
cloud code, talk to this little crab
agent. And this is very similar to sort
of like a chatbt or using cloud in the
web. Now, the way that this works when
you're using Cloud Code in Visual Studio
Code or really wherever you use it is
you have files on the lefth hand side
and then you have your agent on the
right hand side. So, first thing we need
to do is open up a project so that we
can start working with some files. So,
I'm going to go up here to the top left
and I'm going to click on explorer. What
you can see is that it says you have not
yet opened a folder. So, I'm going to go
ahead and open up a fresh folder that
has nothing in it. So, here we are in my
website building YouTube folder, which
like I said, it's a blank project. If
you don't have a folder, just go ahead
and create one. Whether that's in your
desktop or your documents, just create
one to start and then open that up. And
that is where we will be working on this
project. So, let's get started going
through these five hacks. The first one
is actually number zero. And the reason
that I did this is because the first one
is a claw.md file. And I put this as
number zero because it's kind of a
prerequisite, but also a lot of times
near the end, even after 1 2 3 and four,
you might have to rego back and update
your claw.md file or just have claw do
it itself. So, what is [snorts] a
cloud.mmd file? Just think of it as a
system prompt. Think of it as every time
before you ask claude code to do
something, it will read the claw.md file
first. It will always process that. So
what you want to do is make sure that
that is pretty concise. You don't want
to bloat it too much with context. But
you want to give it the rules that it
needs. So every time you are doing
something in this project, this website
building project, do this, this, and
this. And always remember that's kind of
the end goal. And so if you don't
exactly know your full process yet or
the end goal, then you might start
without a claw. MD file. But luckily for
you guys, if you go over to my free
school community, the link for that's
down in the description, you go to the
classroom, you go to claude code, and
right here, you will see the web
designcloud.mmd file, which is the one
we're going to be using today. You can
go ahead and just download that for free
right here. Now, once you've done that,
you can actually just drag it right over
here to the lefth hand side. Like I told
you guys, the lefth hand side is where
we can see our files and our folders.
And what that does is it opens up the
claw.md file, which if I drag over here,
we can see it kind of full screen. Now,
the MD stands for markdown, which is
basically just this right here. We've
got the pound signs, we've got um
asterisks, and it just helps keep the
text organized so that the agent can
read, you know, what's a header, what's
a subheader, what's bold, what are
bullet points, things like that. So, you
could obviously read through this entire
claw. MD file if you want to to kind of
understand what we're telling it to do
in this project. I'm not going to read
everything because you guys can just,
you know, look at it here or download
it. And as we go through these other
hacks, you will see why I put some of
this stuff in here. But that actually
brings me over to our first technically
our first hack which is the front-end
design skill which is why you can see
right here in our cloud.MD the first
thing I wrote is always invoke the
front-end design skill before writing
any front-end code every session no
exceptions. So first of all real quick
what are skills? Well if you go to the
cloud code docs you can read about
skills right here. Essentially they are
custom instructions. So every time you
build like a custom GPT or cloud project
you're usually putting in knowledge and
you're putting in instructions. And
basically skills are just that but in a
markdown file. And why it's so important
and cool is because every time you ask
Claude a question, first it reads its
cla.md file. But then it will think,
okay, the user asked me this. Do I have
any skills in my library that help me do
this better? If yes, I'll grab the
skill, I'll read it, and then I'll take
action. If no, I'll just use my general
knowledge. So that's why we need to have
the front-end skill because it helps us
create designs that are way more modern
and professional and they don't look as
much vibecoded AI vibecoded. And the
good news is it's super super simple.
You just have to install it. So here's a
tweet that showed the power of this. All
they prompted Claude Code to do was use
the front-end design skill, create a
music player app, and it created this
that has some, you know, animations. It
has some dynamic elements. And if you
would have just told Claude Code to do
this without that skill, it would have
looked much worse. So, I'll leave a link
to this tweet in the description of this
video. You basically just have to run
this command and then you run this one
and then you should be good with the
skill installed globally across any
Cloud Code project that you might use in
the future. And when I say run these
commands, you can literally just copy
this if you wanted to and just paste
that right into here in Cloud Code and
it would install that for you. All
right, so let me go ahead and show you
guys how good this front-end design
skill really is with such a minimal
prompt. So, before we prompt this agent,
I just wanted to show you guys something
else you can do, which is kind of a
bonus hack. What I'm going to do is I'm
going to create a new folder. I'm going
to call this brand_assets.
And our claw.md file actually explains
that this might be a file or a folder
that cla code needs to look at. And what
I'm going to put in here are two things,
my logo and brand guidelines so that it
creates this website and it feels very
branded towards me and my business. So
right here I'm dragging in the Amation
Society logo as you can see like that.
And then I'm also going to drag in our
brand guidelines, which has stuff like
our colors, our typography, icons, stuff
like that. And so now that Claude can
look at that, I'm going to just give it
a very, very simple prompt. So all I'm
saying is build me a modern and
professional landing page for AI
Automation Society. And I'm also going
to tell it that here's my logo and
here's my brand guidelines. It would be
able to figure it out either way because
we put it in the claw. MD, but I just
wanted to show you guys that you can
actually tag assets directly. So, if I
do an at, it will basically pop up and
let me choose or point at the right
things. So, now I can explicitly say,
hey, here are the, you know, here's the
brand guidelines and here's the logo
because maybe they're not named in a way
that's super intuitive. And now I'm just
showing Claude Code exactly what I want.
So, I'm going to shoot this off. I'm not
even in plan mode. I just want to show
you guys how good this front-end design
skill is. And what you're going to
notice is first of all, what it did is
it read the cloudmd file and now it's
reading the brand assets. And now what
it's going to do is it should hopefully
invoke the front-end design skill and
start building out that website for us.
There we go. Right on Q. It has invoked
the front-end design skill right there.
All right. So that has finished up. You
can see that we've got a nav, a hero,
tools marquee. We've got stats, about
benefits. So a full onepage landing
page, and it should be completely
matching our brand as far as the logo,
the colors, and the typography. It also
added some animations. So I'm excited to
see how that works. And it threw it on
local host for us to check out. So let's
head over there. All right. Look at
that. We've got like a little animation
up here. We've got a a line going down.
We can see that we do have our logo up
here as well as our exact colors and
font. We've got a community rating. Ooh,
that's super nice. We've also got some
scrolling tech companies. So, we've got
Edit in Make, Claude, GBT40, Zapier, Air
Table. We've got some random stats here.
Obviously, we'd have to fill this in
with our own copy, but keep in mind, all
of this happened with only us saying,
"Create me a landing page for our
community called A Automation Society."
That was literally it and it created all
of this. We've got testimonials. We've
got a final call to action here. The
logo is doing a little floating for
basically a one-s sentence prompt. This
is super super solid with the front-end
design skill. Now, there was another
secret thing going on here that I didn't
yet tell you guys about, but if you've
already read the Claw Denm, you might
have noticed. And that brings us on to
hack number two, which is the screenshot
loop. So, the idea here is that AI is
really good at getting you where you
want to go, but it takes a lot of manual
correction and steering. So, let's say I
just told Claude Code to build us that
website. Without the front-end design
skill, it might have gotten us like 40%
of the way there. But now that we added
the front-end design skill, it's going
to get us maybe let's let's just call it
60. What we can do now is use
screenshots to help AI iterate upon
itself. So, instead of it getting 60% of
the way there and then we make an
improvement and then we make another
improvement and we keep doing this, it
basically should just bridge this gap
itself because it's able to take a
screenshot, look at the browser, see
what it looks like, and then make make
changes. So, what you guys didn't
notice, or maybe you did, is over here,
it created a new folder for us called
temporary screenshots. And we can see
that in that process of building out
that first version of our workflow, it
took 10 screenshots. So, I can click
here and I can see what it looked at. It
looked at the hero section, which kind
of was a a random full page. It got the
viewport, which was that's more of the
hero section. It looked at the stats. It
looked at the about page. And what it
did is it used these screenshots as it
kept clicking through and looking and
improved things. So, you guys didn't see
this, but in the actual to-dos, it wrote
the index html, it started the server
and screenshotted the workflow, and then
it did a two pass screenshot review and
polish. So, it basically uses its eyes
to check that what it's building
actually looks good. And in order to set
that up, it's actually really, really
easy. If you go to the cloud.mmd file,
you can see that I've got a section for
screenshot workflow. And we're just
doing this using Puppeteer. So,
literally, if you take this cloud.md and
say, "Hey, cloud code, can you set up
Puppeteer to take screenshots?" It
should be able to install all of that
stuff for you right there really simply.
And so yes, that's cool on its own, but
where it actually comes into handy a lot
more is when we look at hack number
three, which is using other websites as
inspiration. Because what we're able to
do is say, "Hey, Cloud Code, take this
website right here and build me a
clone." So you should build one that
looks exactly like this one. And then
what it's able to do is use its eyes,
use its screenshot tool to screenshot
what it's building and look at the
reference and keep going back and forth
until it's close enough. So, let me show
you guys that in action right now. So,
there's tons of sites that you could go
to for website inspiration. Here's one
example called Dribble. Here's another
example called godly website. And here's
another really cool example called
Awards with three W's. So, there's tons
of places that you can find inspiration.
So, for the sake of this video, I found
this one that I want to use. It's got a
nice little animation in the background.
It's obviously not our color scheme, but
it has some cool things as you scroll
down like a dashboard. It's got some
other little cards down here. None of
this is really too animated. Well, I
guess that is. But let's just say we
wanted our website to look like this
one, for example. First thing that I
would do is I would hit F12. I'm on
Windows, by the way. I would go to
console and I would do control shiftp
and search for screenshot. What this
lets me do is capture a full-size
screenshot of the entire page rather
than just my current view.
So here you can see it downloaded this
screenshot and you can see that that is
indeed the entire website. Now if you're
on Mac that's still doable, but you just
have to Google the different buttons to
do it. And then the next thing what I
want to do is on the top right here I'm
going to go to elements and in the style
section down here I'm just going to copy
everything. So I'm actually copying
basically like the raw code or HTML or
you know whatever you want to consider
this as that tells the website how this
is styled. And we're going to give
Claude code that. So, I'm going to go
ahead and do a clear so we can start a
fresh session. I'm going to first of all
just paste in the code that we just
copied, which is the style information.
So, I said, I want you to spin up a new
website for us. Get rid of the old one
and you can put this one on local host.
I basically want you to clone this
website. So, I'm going to give you the
screenshot, which what I'm going to do
is just drag it in from my files and put
it right over here. As you can see, that
is the screenshot we just took. And I'm
going to point to it so it knows what to
use, which is the www right there. And
then I said, here's a screenshot. here's
the style and just go ahead and clone
this website for us. So that is all
we're going to do to start and then we
can come back in later and tell it to
use our branding and our you know colors
and logo and everything like that. Now a
couple things to keep in mind when
you're doing some of the big processes
like spinning up a website from scratch
or comparing to websites and cloning
them that coding process and thinking
will take longer. But once you have a
working version making small changes or
tweaks that happens pretty quickly. And
one other thing is you might have
noticed that this really isn't stopping
to ask me questions. And that's because
I'm using bypass permissions mode. So if
you don't see this in your instance,
you're going to go to settings. You're
going to type in clawed code. And then
right here, you should see allow
dangerously skip permissions. And that
is where you turn that on. Now I
definitely have a responsibility to tell
you that this is dangerous. It has the
potential to just kind of like run any
command that it wants. But in my
practice, I've never really had this be
an issue, especially because I'm never
like setting this to code all night long
and then going to sleep. I'm always
still kind of like watching it or I'm
nearby and nothing bad really is going
to happen. All right, awesome. So, we
just got to the point where now it is
creating a to-do list. And what you can
see here is once it actually writes the
code for the website, it's going to
start up the server and it's going to
take screenshots and it's going to do
two rounds at least of comparing. It's
going to look at what it built versus
the reference. It's going to fix any
mismatches and then it's going to do
that again. And that is why the
screenshot loop is so powerful. So
logically, this is really cool. I mean,
it's going through and it's looking
section by section and analyzing how
well it's stacking up. But we will have
to see how it actually turns out. Okay,
so that just finished up and before we
actually see how good it really built
this, I wanted to point out one thing
about the screenshots. So you can see
that we have screenshot 1 2 3 4 all this
kind of stuff. But we don't really know
which one is which without clicking on
them. So, it looks like these are the
clones as you can see because they're
coming out looking like the website that
we gave it. Well, we either should have
before we started this new build, we
should have told cloud code, hey, you
can delete all of those temporary
screenshots or in the claw.md, we should
be more specific about the naming
convention of the screenshots so that we
can actually tell. Now, realistically,
these temporary screenshots are more for
Claude codes benefit than for ours, but
that is something else that you can be
thinking about if you do want to be able
to click through and see the changes
that were made with each version. But
anyways, let's go ahead and open up this
link and see what we got. All right, so
I'm going to switch this to English for
my head. But we can see we've got the
purple colors. We've got your strategic
ally for a truly profitable business.
We've got the same top menu bar. Um a
similar type of dashboard here. We've
got some cards. And as we scroll down,
it feels very similar to the real
version that we gave it, which was this
one. Obviously, some of the dynamic
elements in the background and some of
the actual images could not have been
the exact same, but for a clone, this is
very, very similar. And it is a really
good spot for us to actually start. And
now we can just start to integrate our
own colors and logos and copy right into
this template. And it's as simple as
just asking it to do so. So, I'm going
to go ahead and clear this out. I'm
going to say go ahead and delete all of
the temporary screenshots in the
temporary screenshots folder. And so now
all of those have been deleted as you
can see. And we're basically going to
say the most recent landing page looks
really good. What I want you to do now
is work in our brand assets. So our
brand guidelines and our AIS logo. And
this is for our community called AI
Automation Society. So just work in
those changes to that website clone that
you just built. And once again, we are
just going to stay on bypass
permissions. I'm going to shoot that
off. One shot prompt this thing. And
hopefully we should get something that
looks pretty solid. Now, what I'm
interested to see is what it ends up
doing with this dashboard and what it
ends up doing with this iPhone screen
because we haven't given it any other
pictures. As you saw in our website, we
obviously gave it some different
pictures like the school games dashboard
or me with Hermosi and Sam Ovens. But
that's what you could do is you would
come back into Claude Code and you would
say, "Hey, I gave you some more pictures
in the brand assets. Put this one here.
Put this one there." And it would figure
that out for you. And of course, you
would also have to say, "Cool. When they
click on start for free, take them to
this link." or when they click on see
the demo, take them to this link. So,
there's other little pieces that you
would obviously have to configure as
well, but those changes take basically
no time. Okay, so that finished up
pretty quickly. We've got three
screenshots here, but I'm not going to
click into them because I don't want to
ruin the final reveal here. But it used
our colors. We have our primary accent,
our secondary, our dark background, and
our mid background. We've got the right
typography. We've got the right logo,
and everything was fully translated from
French to English, thank goodness. And
now it's rewritten for our community,
which once again, we didn't actually
give it facts about the community yet.
This is just very simple prompting. It
also mocked up a dashboard. So, let's
head over to our local host. Let's give
this a hard refresh. And boom. We now
have our new site, Master A Automation,
Build Faster, Earn more. For the
dashboard, it worked in like a little
bit of a it's got members. It's got
automations, courses. It's got it's kind
of like a community tracker dashboard,
and it uses our colors in there, too,
which is cool. We've got different
things on here, workshops, templates,
expert community. It also changed this
iPhone thing to member growth this
month. So, it's keeping all of this on
brand with the actual original reference
site, which once again looked like this.
However, now it has our colors and it
has our information in here. We've got
two paths and then we have some other
stats down here and a nice little call
to action at the bottom. So, cool. What
we could do now is obviously go back and
forth a little bit, maybe change some
text, make things bigger, you know,
change the images and stuff like that.
But let's say we're at a spot where we
like the overall feel and vibe of the
website. But now, how do we really up it
to the next level to make it feel
unique? Well, what we're going to do is
unlock the final hack, which is
individual components. And what I mean
by that is taking inspiration from
different places, but for very
individual components for small pieces,
not entire websites. So, what we can do
is we can go to a website called
21st.dev,
which has some of the best website
components you might be able to find.
It's got shaders. It's got backgrounds.
It's got home screens. It's got buttons.
It's got, you know, mouse highlights.
It's got so many different things that
you can do. So, here you can see I've
got buttons. And I could make them have
a rainbow outline. I could make them
shiny. We could toggle, you know, dark
mode or light mode. There's lots of
different things we could do here. Or I
could just click on backgrounds in here,
and I could look at other ways that we
could have our background. So, maybe we
want these little kind of drop down
pills instead. Or maybe we want these
hero waves in the background. I think we
should actually do this instead. So,
what I'm going to do is just copy this
prompt right here. This will basically
copy a chunk of code for us to give to
cloud code. And I'm just going to say, I
want you to work in this background
element right behind the hero text. And
after I give it that prompt, I just
paste in what we grabbed from 21st. And
it should be able to use all of this and
understand how to put that into our
site. So, I'm just going to go ahead and
shoot this off and we will see.
Actually, one thing that I forgot to
mention is in this case, because we're
working with an animation, the
screenshot might not always work the
best. So, sometimes you might want to
tell it not to do the screenshot flow.
So, I'm basically actually just going to
copy all of this text. Once again, I'm
going to clear this out. I'm going to
paste it back in. But then I'm also
going to say,
because this is an animated background,
do not use the screenshot tool to
compare. just work in the code and then
I will let you know if we need to make
any changes. So hopefully with that
mentioned even though it's going to read
the cloudMD, it won't do a bunch of
screenshots here because I've actually
tested this out and I've had you know
different background elements come
through and because they're dynamic
sometimes the screenshot doesn't fully
capture it. So it gets stuck in this
loop of thinking I haven't built this
good enough. I'm going to keep trying
and it like overengineers and it just
doesn't really work. So sometimes you
may want to turn off the screenshot
tool. All right, so that just finished
up. It didn't take a bunch of
screenshots, so it didn't take forever.
Let's go to the website. Let's give it a
refresh and see.
Okay. Okay. So, we've got a background.
It looks a little bit um distracting. It
also looks a little bit cheap. It looks
like too pixelated. So, what I'm going
to do now is just iterate. I'm going to
tell it that
I think that it's a little bit
distracting as far as it makes the hero
text right behind it a little bit tough
to read. Also, in the hero text, I'd
like it if the earn more was maybe a
blue or a different color. I think that
doesn't really feel good to have that be
orange. It would be good if there was
maybe some sort of background behind the
hero text so that we could see it and it
would still stand out and contrast
against the background animation, but
the background animation looks super
fuzzy and super pixy. If you could make
that look a little bit more professional
and clean, that would be great. And if
you guys were curious why I was just
like staring at that and talking is
because I was dictating and I wanted to
be able to look at what I was talking
about. So we've given some feedback now.
Let's see if it can go ahead and make
those changes. And once again, like
we're being pretty vague here and it
would be up to the creativity of the
model to understand what we're asking
for and be able to make these changes.
Now, if you were on plan mode, it might
be able to do a little bit better job of
asking you some questions and maybe
helping you get to a better solution
first before it starts coding. But for
the sake of the video, let's see how
well it does with this prompt. All
right, that just finished up. And you
can see that that looks much, much
better. This is definitely more what I
was looking for when we copied over that
animation into this website. So from
here, we would just keep going through
and we keep being really nitpicky about
what we want to change. We'd add our own
pictures in. We'd maybe want to change
some of these buttons to be more
dynamic. We'd want to maybe animate some
of this other stuff, which we could
easily do just by asking Claude Code to
do so. So from here the question is how
do you actually get this onto a real
landing page? Because right now we're
still developing all of this code and
we're previewing this in our local host.
So what we're going to do is we're going
to use a combination of GitHub and
Verscell to do this. Cloud code is where
we're working right now. All of these
folders, all of these files are local.
Meaning if I pulled up my laptop, I
wouldn't be able to access them. And
when we're building our website, which
is obviously this website right here,
this is all made up of a bunch of code
in our cloud code project. So what we
need to do with that is we sync that
code to GitHub and GitHub has version
control. We can see all of our commits,
other people can work on it, stuff like
that. We basically host our code or our
project in the cloud and we set up a
really cool autodeploy between Verscell
and GitHub. And Verscell is basically
just where we deploy our code to a live
site. So basically what this means is
whenever we tell cloud code, hey this
looks good, push these changes to
GitHub, GitHub grabs the new changes and
then Verscell automatically grabs those
from GitHub and then updates the real
working version of our site and I will
show you guys that. But let's first of
all do this pipeline. So the first thing
that you're going to need to do is go to
GitHub, create an account if you don't
already have one, and you're going to
need to create a new repository. So I'm
going to create a repository right here
called AIS test website. I'm not going
to worry right now about a description
or all of this and I'm just going to go
ahead and create that repository. Now,
what you also could do is you could tell
Claude Code, hey, create me a GitHub
repository and it could actually do
that. But right now, I just wanted to
show you guys so you can get a feel for
GitHub if you've never used it before.
So, anyways, now we have this repository
called AIS test website. I'm just going
to copy the name of that real quick and
I'm going to come back into Cloud Code.
We're going to clear this out and say
awesome. So now that this site looks
good, we need to actually deploy this on
our domain. I need you to help push this
to GitHub and we're going to push it to
a GitHub repository called
and then I'm going to paste in the name.
Now, so far it has not yet gotten our
GitHub credentials. So we're going to
have to obviously authenticate into
GitHub first so it can push that into
GitHub. So I just got logged in as Nate
Herkai and now it's going to create
the.get ignore and get everything set up
so it can actually do so. Now, it's not
too big of a deal right now because
nothing that we'd be pushing into the
public GitHub or, you know, onto the
cloud has API keys or has any usernames
or passwords or any sensitive
information or, you know, web hook
abilities. But that is something to be
aware of once you actually are pushing
automations and things like that to the
cloud. Make sure that you're not putting
any of your sensitive information out
there. Awesome. So, it now says that our
site is live on GitHub. So, if I click
into this link, we should see that we
now have a new commit. We have all of
this stuff like our claw.md. We have our
screenshot stuff. We have brand assets
and now we can sync this to Verscell. So
that would be step two is you're going
to go to verscell.com create an account.
When you create that account, it's much
easier if you just sign in or create
that account with your GitHub
credentials and then all we have to do
is go ahead and add a new project. And
then we're able to just choose a GitHub
repository. As simple as that. So I can
literally just hit import on our AIS
test website, which you guys just saw me
set up. And then all I have to do is go
ahead and deploy this project. Awesome.
So I've deployed a new project to my
project. I can go ahead and continue to
the dashboard here. And what this now
does is we can actually visit this by
going to ais-est
website.verell.app.
I open that up and now this is no longer
local. I could open up my phone and type
in this. You could open up your browser
and type this in. And you guys could all
visit this site because it's now
deployed on the cloud. But of course,
it's got an ugly domain. So what you
would have to do now is you would have
to go to your project settings. You
would go to domains. And then this is
where you would actually just have to
either buy a domain right here or add an
existing one. And it's really simple. It
would walk you through the DNS
configuration that you need to set up.
And it's not too difficult, but I'm not
going to actually do that live in this
video. So, what I wanted to show you
guys real quick before we end off this
video is what actually happens if we
realize that we want to make a change to
our website that is on the cloud. Well,
that's why it's good that we still have,
you guys can't see because you can't see
the URL, but we still do have our local
version because if I make a change here
and I don't like it, I don't want that
to automatically get pushed to um
Verscell. So, what you'd probably want
to do is in your claw.md file, you would
say ultimately what's going to happen is
we're syncing all of the changes to
GitHub. GitHub's going to automatically
push them to Verscell and we'll be good
to go. But when I'm making changes with
you here, we're always going to test on
a local host until I tell you explicitly
to push that to GitHub or commit those
changes to GitHub. Okay. So this is our
local version. And let's just say for
example, we wanted to make this button a
little bit cooler. So I'm going to ask
in cloud code, could you go ahead and
make the join the community button in
the main hero text section, make it more
professional. So give it like a cool
glow. And once you've made this change,
let me see it in local host. Don't push
it to GitHub until I tell you to. This
thing is getting pretty screenshot
happy. I may have to adjust the wording
in the cloud.MD file a little bit. It
literally took one of the main screen
and then it took one of where it just
cropped the actual button, but hey, it
looks good. Okay, so what happens is
here's the local host. I'll refresh
that. Now we can see the little glow
behind the join the community button and
here is the web app version. I refresh
this and we don't have that change yet,
which is great because we don't want to
push changes if they're not good, right?
But now what I'll do is say awesome. I
love that change. Go ahead and push that
to GitHub. All right, so it just pushed
that. We have a new commit. If I go to
GitHub and I give this a refresh, we can
see that we should see right here two
commits. This one was add glowing pulse
effect to hero join the community
button. And then if I go to versel and
we go to our deployments, we should see
that we just got a second one come
through as well just now. And now if I
go to the site on the web and I refresh,
we see the actual glowing join the
community button. All right, so those
are the five hacks that I wanted to
cover today. We have our claw.md file,
which as you could tell by this video,
yes, it's nice to have something to
start, but you are going to continue to
iterate upon it throughout your project
until you get to a good spot. We've got
the front-end design skill, which is
just like way too easy to not use. We've
got the screenshot loop, which you got
to be careful about, but it is very
helpful. We've got inspiration websites,
and then we have inspiration individual
components, and now it's just a matter
of making small tweaks and iterating
upon your website. Just a reminder, you
can grab this claw.md file for free in
my free school community. The link for
that is down in the description. And if
you're looking to dive deeper with cloud
code, AI automation, building an AI
agency, all this kind of stuff, then
definitely check out our paid community,
AI Automation Society Plus. Got a great
community of thousands of members in
here who are building businesses with
AI. And we've also got a full course
with tons of more content coming over
the next few months. So, we'd love to
see you guys in this community. But
anyways, that's going to do it for
today. If you guys enjoyed the video or
you learned something new, please give
it a like. Definitely helps me out a
ton. And as always, I appreciate you
guys making it to the end of the video.
I'll see you on the next one. Thanks
everyone.